[Music]
hey what's going on you guys you can't
really see the chair in the background
right let me see all kind of crap back
there just
[Laughter]
noticing well like I said you didn't to
come in here for a couple minutes before
so it's all right yeah we're just like
blocking it we're just blocking it see
light looks all right right
yeah looks about I don't know looks we
look a little washed out I think I don't
know what do you guys think see here let
me look here no it's all right yeah lot
of
Shadows well I don't know I can't see it
on your [__] so I don't really know it's
okay I don't really know what's going on
i' probably darken it just a little bit
all right well it's probably it's
probably that pink one right in front of
my face that's doing that probably what
it is okay I don't know that looks even
more shadowy but I
will oh well so what's up everybody it's
Friday Jeffy art says happy Friday
waiting at the pizzeria for my pie to be
done next time I'm doing delivery yeah
we're uh getting ready to uh go to the
club in a bit yeah we're going to do uh
mannequins again I think I was for some
reason I was thinking it was momento
this Friday but then I guess they didn't
do it this Friday because um the
Absolution Fest is going on in Tampa
yeah it's like a big goth Music Festival
yeah it's like three days yeah which I
would get him for free but I can't
really afford the gas hotel and the
drinks and [__] like that I think a star
night's playing tonight though oh are
they [__] I think they're I I can't
remember if they're playing I thought
they were playing Friday I did all the
posters but it was a bunch of band so I
couldn't remember what
day everybody's still piling in yeah
everybody piling Zach says Zach Sam as
Goths isn't waged out the idea what does
that mean I don't know
I think some of those words are are the
wrong words yeah must have been spell
check we yeah we'll figure it out in a
[Laughter]
minute but yeah I don't know how many
people are going to be going to that but
because Tampa is kind of a long drive
from here kind of a long
drive well not from here from Orlando
it's about an hour and a half and I
think a lot of people go like every year
cuz it's cool I mean we've been the
last when did they start doing it they
started doing it probably like four or 5
years ago I don't know yeah why is my
[__] phone ringing I don't know this
shit's been ringing [__] constantly
every time I come in here they're
calling you and it's always and it's
always like spam risk or telemarketer
yeah can you turn the ringer off yeah
and it's like I that's the thing I
thought I turned it off but it somehow
just I don't know if the phone restarted
and it turned it back on I don't [__]
know what that phone's doing it's been
dropped so it does all kind of crazy
[__] uh let's see Zach says so the
podcast I submitted my screenplay to
that does dramatic reads dropped their
episode for it the other day and it's so
damn funny why did they drop
it yeah I remember submitting a story to
one of those things before but I don't
know if they ever put it on if they ever
read it or anything like that
but but yeah so yeah we're all kind of
ready to go out this evening should be
fun hopefully we don't spend as much
money as we did last time we got a
little carried away
what's that last time last time it made
a yeah we spent like 13 I was like
whoops yeah we were drinking the [__]
out of the yeah we were and we had drank
before we went too so it it's just kind
of like I'm surprised I even remembered
anything
yeah it's all right we made it back it
was it was a fun night though it was a
fun night not like I was totally
inebriated or anything yeah I mean yeah
that's what I mean we
weren't and it's like and it's over
several hours and it's like we were
dancing time I've always drink like a
bunch of water like in between so it
wasn't too bad then we always eat when
we get home sandwiches from Circle K
yep that's what we do on uh every Friday
is that we Usher in the weekend and uh
sometimes we'll be going out for the
weekend sometimes we're staying
in and just kind of catch up with the
with uh our subscribers and our fans
online fans here um tonight we're going
to be going out and uh white girl
whisper is going to be there oh is he oh
okay I I want to meet the white girl
whis my boy L yeah he's going to be
there he couldn't come last week right
he's going to be there say he's going to
stop in okay we'll see a lot of times
people say that and then they never they
never do he said he would but we'll see
he's in that area where he said he
should be kind of fun I mean it's more
it's usually more fun like when the
normies leave
yeah see if you get there early like
they're kind of it wasn't too bad last
week like Normie wise yeah but there
were some kind there was some there was
some Normy action yeah yeah the jocks
were out there yeah acting a [__]
fool well that's just not knowing how to
[__] dance they had their girls with
them it's a shame because
man they look good you know what I mean
the dudes are [__] big and strong
they look pretty good they got [__]
good-looking women with them but they
just don't know how to [__] act in a
club and they're just watching the
[__] videos as they're playing
they're like what what what kind of
music is this they're dancing to it but
all wrong you know what I mean and
they're [__] taking pictures of
themselves dancing with the music with
the like look where we are you know what
I mean it's like [__] tourist ass
[__] you know what I mean it just yeah
there's been very few of them that know
how to handle themselves in a [__]
subculture Club yeah very few well like
I said I think they get like insecure so
they go the opposite direction and be
like look at me look at me yeah so
[__] cool yeah it's like we're in a
we're in a fck it's like we're at
amusement park look at this look at all
these people I'm fitting
in no you're
not you're driving everybody else off
the dance floor cuz you don't and then
cuz you're flailing around yeah yeah and
then like U or they're just standing
there or they're just standing there uh
[__] that's that's one thing about uh
the uh [__] Paul the DJs a friend of
ours he started to go no douchebags on
the Dance Floor no douchebags and they
all laugh he doesn't realize that
they're talking about them I'm like
they're talking about you they talking
about you you're a douchebag give a [__]
they're like oh like yeah yeah you guys
came one of the things he came in last
came in and said last time I was there
is you cannot stand on the Dance Floor
he says no parking the dance floor yeah
no parking they need a big sign that
says that although I they wouldn't read
it the dance floor is for dancing if you
want to stand around go out back on the
patio yeah and a lot of them left yeah
but they have to be reminded oh yeah I
guess I just can't stand in the middle
of the dance floor and watch people
dance [__] retards
man [__] [__] drinking her hand
just
watch you know likeu three or four Dudes
just standing there staring at some
[__] chick yeah what the [__] man
it's uh like we're in the middle of
Pakistan and they never seen a girl
dance [__] is this [__]
man you're a you're a poshon tribesman
now in Afghanistan you're appalled that
a woman's dancing [__] out here I mean
in this day and age when you can see
pretty much anything you can see on the
internet yeah I mean yeah I I don't
understand like why they act like like
they act like these like openmouth
Rubes I don't know man just fell off the
[__] turn truck the club the club is
on a [__] little downtown Street
downtown Sanford it's on a little street
that has like uh Mexican restaurants uh
it's got Throwbacks it's like a soul
food restaurant yeah it's got isn't
there like another bar across the street
yep there's another bar it's just a
[__] basic [__] bar and um then it's
it's got Throwbacks which is I like
Throwbacks Throwbacks is a [__] retro
80s [__] themed arcade that has a bar
in it and [__] pool T he goes there
on bike night sometimes and all the
video games are free they got all the CL
oh see I didn't even know that games are
free awesome yeah well [__] I'm going to
have to and it's the oneup games it's
not the it's not the originals it's the
the oneup reproductions still but
they're still good and like the Street
Fighter game the Capcom game's got like
eight games on it and it's got puzzle
fighter I like P I like puzzle fighter
which I had forgotten all about that you
brought puzzle fighter that's like the
[__] that's like Street Fighter meets
Tetris but it's just a different version
you
know it's pretty cool I like I like it
um they got the they got all the Star
Wars games the old classic Star Wars
games and then uh oh man they have they
have a bunch of them they probably have
about 15 games but each each each
console's got multiple games on it I
mean video games and a bar you can't
really go wrong with that yeah that's a
great [__] concept M it's where bike
Knight used to be centered around but
they kicked us out cops kicked us out
damn cops yeah too many people yeah they
were getting and and that's the thing
too they've they've kind of cracked down
down there for whatever reason and it's
just kind of like now you can't you used
to be able to park there was this
massive dirt lot next to mannequins it
was like literally right there
and they used to let you park in there
and now you're not allowed to park in
there anymore so now you have to like
parallel park on the street which kind
of sucks too many people with bike night
there was too many people we were taking
up all the parking yeah and uh they
weren't buying anything they weren't
buying M many drinks from they just kind
of hang out outside yeah and then
they're taking up all the parking for
all the restaurants they got pissed I
mean I can kind of see that like if
you're taking up all the parking but
still I mean they still do it down there
they just moved it I I don't know where
they moved it but they moved it into a
parking lot outside that place that has
all the [__] sandwiches salvatory
sandwich oh okay yeah yeah all right I
know where that is I know where that is
it didn't stop anything it just moved us
out of that area yeah I mean cuz they
could I mean they could just put you
somewhere like that is closed you can
still go to Throwbacks just you can't go
down there in a giant [__] hoorde
right you
know and park all over the [__] so
everybody's like well I would like to
park here too I remember when we went
down there last
Halloween and it was [__] man we
couldn't find a parking space to save
our [__] lives it was [__] packed
down there yeah we were we we it took us
so long to find a parking space that we
were almost just going to go home cuz
we're like [__] it there's no place to
park but finally we found one like
somebody left but I remember that I was
getting frustrated yeah I me you
couldn't even Park in the you couldn't
even Park in the residential areas no
you couldn't Park everything around
there was just like it's not like you
could park just villion people you'd
have to walk mile to get in there and
mannequins was so crowded that it's like
you couldn't dance you couldn't it took
forever to get a drink I mean it was
still fun but it was just there was
[__] people ever I don't know how
many people people were in that place
that night Zach said still uh y'all
should dress as normies for Halloween
one year I we would stick out yeah
that's what I mean now it's like our
friend Shauna did that one year yeah but
she did it different though but she kind
of did it it wasn't really a normie but
kind of did a no it's a 1970s black
chick yeah old 1970s black chick with
the curlers hair gray hair and [__]
like tacky [__] bell bottoms they
were like rayon they were like [__] you
got from the [__] it was so funny
yeah yeah and but it would probably only
be funny if you knew her yeah like what
she normally nobody knew what she if you
didn't know what she normally looked
like it wouldn't it wouldn't stand out
as much yeah she I you know I felt
somebody was standing behind me in the
club this is this is we were at uh that
was what was the name of that place it
was uh that was at iar I bar yeah at I
bar felt somebody standing behind me
turned around there this [__] old
black chick standing there looking at me
crazy what whoa
that's yeah we don't recognize put
recognizer man yeah it was a good
costume though it really good it looks
really good
yeah Zach says I think I Googled
mannequins once and couldn't believe a
whole ass Club can fit inside such a
small building um yeah it's no you're
only seeing one entrance yeah it's not
as small as it look small as you think
yeah because it's actually well wait a
minute what
two storefronts that were combined yeah
yeah cuz it used to be two like when it
first opened it was just like one of
them and then there was some other [__]
next door but then he bought the store
next door cuz it was closing it's de and
knocked a wall out yeah it's real deep
and it has like a big uh patio in the
back like he did a covered patio kind of
and um you know he kind of uh what's the
what's the word I'm looking for like put
down flooring and [__] like that like
tiled it and stuff so uh so yeah so the
back and they have a DJ out there
sometimes too so that's there wasn't one
last time but they just kind of had they
kind of stopped DJ DJ back there because
it was getting too loud and and they
were complaining yeah because it's not
far from a residential yeah neighborhood
I mean it's zoned for that but and
there's other bars and stuff but the
technically I thought the bars in
Sanford closed early like I thought they
were supposed to close by like
midnight but mannequin does mannequin
stays up until 2:30 far as I know cuz I
think we've stayed till closing a couple
of times usually we leave before then
though
yeah um Zach says if you guys ever come
to Indiana I'm taking y'all to Greg's
it's the biggest gay bar downtown and
it's a damn trip oh I would totally love
that I can't really foresee myself going
to
Indiana well in case not much there you
never know we might just end up there
somehow I don't think i' I've never been
to Indiana yeah not that I can remember
but yeah I'm trying to think of like
some other [__] that we could uh talk
about oh this is kind of exciting so
this is how my day
started so Tom cut my hair this morning
cuz you know I had to shave it and stuff
like that and then we had brought we had
bought some new nipple jewelry yeah I
forgot about that a good story so he's
going to change the cuz I can't really
do it cuz I can't see it's like a bad
angle yeah they're hot they're hot yeah
yeah so so he bought these yeah they're
really cool they like obious I can't
show them obviously but it's just kind
of like um it's kind of like a ring and
it has t of these beads on it it's a bar
yeah had with two beads yeah and then
hanging from the bar underneath the
nipple is like a crescent moon
shaped piece of metal that's all
scalloped yeah and it holds a pearl
yeah so it's just like a it's like a big
[__] just a big and they're kind of
heavy just like a heavy piercing they're
[__] hot you see them a lot in you
know [__] a lot of a lot of uh what
do you call them um adult entertainers
yeah a lot of adult
entertainmententertainment girls you see
wearing them every now and then they got
big boobs they'll have
them but yeah it's just a different kind
of bar it looks like a ring kind of but
it's not yeah it's got a bar but with
like a ring on the bottom like half half
moon ring on the bot so so he changed
the first one out yeah and I'm just like
standing there and he's changed them out
like lots of times they're hard to
change out they are hard to change out
because it's like it's not a huge hole
and it's just kind of like you can't you
know the ball at the end of the bar like
you have to screw on is like really
small and it's like yeah and the ball
has got a hole in it dropping it and you
got to hold it straight and you're
trying to spit it you can't it's tiny
it's and your V my vision isn't very
good anymore yeah so it's you can't find
the hole in the ball right and you can't
hold it straight it's hard then you got
to tighten it and you got to do it
without hurting her yeah cuz you know
there's not a lot of clearance and some
I had to sometimes you have to use
pliers I was using needlenose pliers to
do the so you got these needlenose
pliers right next to the I know I'm just
like I don't even want to look at
this yeah but yeah so he took out the
first one and he was putting it in put
putting the new one in and I'm standing
there and it hurt kind of but not a lot
but then I was just all of a sudden I
was like oh I don't feel too good I said
I think I'm gonna black out yeah I'm
going why yeah well it yeah it's it hurt
but not any more than usual but just for
whatever reason I was just kind of like
oh [__] I think I'm going to black out
so I sat down like on the toilet I'm
like oh man I I don't feel too good I
think I'm going to pass out and um and
he's like it's you know it shouldn't
hurt it shouldn't I was like well it
kind of does though and then and then I
was like I I need to lay down I need to
lay down so he's like okay so he takes
my hand and we took her to like walk to
the bedroom and the next thing I knew
there was like this huge crash yeah and
I thought I was waking up in bed still
and I was going to ask you what was that
noise and then it was me like passing
out yeah she passed out while she was
walking yeah [__] crumpled out on the
ground she got right back up though yeah
well I woke up I was like what the [__]
just happened cuz I was just about to
ask you what that noise was and then I
realized oh that was me hitting the
floor that noise was fainted it's
totally psychological it's so weird was
cuz when I stuck that bar through you
know went went through the hole
perfectly it didn't wasn't any problem
it was just you you had some kind of
flashback well this what this one kind
of hurts a little bit more I don't know
if we made did some kind of like nerve
damage or something like that when we
were piercing it but it doesn't it's not
like super painful but this one is like
more sore than the other one and the
weird thing about it is that after that
happened like all the rest of today like
now I have this weird pain like it's
really painful like right underneath
here like by my rib cage and like up
into my shoulder and stuff so I'm
wondering if like there's some nerve
like if we pinched a nerve or something
probably pinch a nerve it'll probably go
away I hope so yeah should go away but I
couldn't BL I haven't passed out for a
long time I used to pass out all the
time cuz I was just cuz I have um I have
really really low blood pressure and
always have done so seriously all I have
to do is like I'll be sitting on the
floor and I'll get up too fast and I'll
be like oh you know what I mean so it'll
be kind of like that but um but I hadn't
actually passed out for a long I think
the last time I thought I was going to
pass out was when you pierced them in
the first place and I didn't actually
pass out then I almost did but I was
kind of able to fight back to it but
this one I it was weird because I
thought I was okay like we were cuz cuz
you have my hand and I was like oh I
still felt crappy but I was like I think
I can make it to the bedroom and then
all of a sudden I woke up and I'm like
what the [__] happened what time did
mannequins open 9 9:30 yeah something
like that something like that yeah we
don't
um yeah Mandy Nicole said you can do
nerve damage uh my man passed out too
while changing his nipple jewelry back
in the day weird next time have a little
bit of sugar before changing them yeah
maybe that's what it was cuz I don't
think I'd eaten breakfast or anything
like that when you changed them out
could have been so I had didn't I didn't
either and the other one was no problem
yeah well the other one I was like I
think I'm going to go lay down on the
floor like when you do it so just I had
her laying down sideways in the sun like
in the sunlight from the window open the
shad and he's like here
like it's just yeah like I said they
look really good but they're kind of a
pain in the ass to change and I can't
change them do they pull it all um they
yeah they're okay I just had to be like
really really careful I have to be
really careful all right especially if
I'm like when I'm putting things on or
taking things off because you have to
watch like stuff will catch yeah and
then it'll like it'll the ring will pull
yeah you don't have as much of a problem
with the bar but this one has a ring so
I have to be like super careful about it
cuz every now and then like I'll whack
it with a towel or something like when
I'm getting out of the shower I'm just
like you know what I
mean it's a it's it's a kind of a kind
of a yucky
feeling Zach says about Indiana the
state MTO was originally the crossroads
of America and the local joke is you
have to drive through it to get
somewhere
[Laughter]
better then he also says Tom just sounds
like he's talking about penetration he
usually is I mean what you talking about
when you're talking about putting the
nipple in I guess yeah maybe yeah greens
spark said mine kept getting caught on
my bra and pulling I was too nervous to
change it out myself so I took them out
I would have passed out too okay at at
least I don't feel too bad and I guess
that's a thing I guess it's
psychologically unnerving well it is
unnerving it's a very very sensitive
area okay when you're doing it it just
slips in yeah I know but it's like it's
it's a really sensitive area so like
when somebody is [__] around like
right there you're not what's going to
happen's happen so the stress it's like
yeah even if it doesn't hurt all that
much it's just kind of like oh this
could go really wrong yeah Mandy said um
it's a blood pressure drop yeah I've
worked at a tattoo piercing shop for
years and usually people only pass out
if they don't eat before okay also the
complete heal time is one year all right
that's you'll be okay yeah and going
through that nipple material I didn't
expect it to be that tough that shit's
[__] tough man I still can't believe
we did that [__] oh my God yeah like
back on it I'm like had I known it was
going to be that crazy if had I known it
was going to be like that I wouldn't
have done it I don't think I had done it
yeah but got it done it's a good job
yeah it looks great yeah it's just uh
just that was kind of psychologically
[__] uh stressful for me doing it me
also push you know and I made one
mistake where I I could have
just pushed that bar out out with the
new needle and then put the second bar
in instead of [__] doing the whole
thing over again you're just using one
bar to push the other bar out cuz I
accidentally used a too small of a
needle the first time I could have just
pushed pushed that out with a larger
needle put a larger needle behind it and
swelled the hole up some it it work just
cuz I kind of freaked out when when we
before we did it because um yeah when I
saw the size of the needle yeah that was
going in yeah it's big and then I was
just kind of like yeah I don't know if I
want to do I was going whoa
yeah you know I you during certain
during certain [__] anabolic [__]
therapy Cycles you know I'll give myself
an injection every day or every other
day depending on what the H what the
hell I'm doing and so I got real used to
sticking needles in myself I just and me
because he gives me injection I never
really the thing is it was the material
in legs and in arms and [__] like like
that is easy to go through especially
with these little gauge needles these
bigger needles going through tough
tougher [__] materials is rough yeah
it's not like doing a belly button
piercing or an ear piercing where you're
just going through fat you know that's
nothing yeah this is going through a
[__] real tough material stretchy I
didn't and it pops and crunches I didn't
[__] think know that it would have
that feeling it's popping and crunching
and she's going a and I'm going oh [__]
too late now I got to go through it I
got to do it you and then when one's
done you go like you she she was like I
don't know if I went to do the other on
she took a long break yeah I waited like
an hour or two and then I was kind of
dreaded going back every time every time
we see somebody in the skin industry
[__] only girl has one of them we
both go H we know Happ we know happened
there I'm like I I don't blame you yeah
I wasn't going to come back and get the
second either it was awful like I had to
wait like an hour or two hours or
something like that and then I was like
oh yeah had her ass laying down that was
it was so bad
but it was kind of like like I said it
was kind of like a r of Passage kind of
thing I'm glad I did it I would not do
it again though once they were done she
loved them she's like oh they look great
yeah they do look really cool it's just
Dak says cool earrings by the way Jenny
thank you very much yeah I don't get to
wear these too much because usually have
a wig on so it's covered my ears up well
hey ganthers he says my Prince Albert
Pearson gets caught in my zipper all the
time you don't have
a don't see too many Prince Alberts you
do see in in porn a lot of the girls do
have nipple piercings and a lot of them
have like libia piercings too I see a
couple clip piercings also yeah I don't
think I'd want to do that nah just get a
belly button piercing yeah I probably
would when it goes I don't think the I
don't think bar with a little charm that
holds yeah I don't think the one in the
lebia would be that painful I mean
nothing could be as painful as the
nipple one I just I can't see Jenny is
[__] killing it in the gym [__]
killing it I'm killing it she's yeah she
she's [__] like getting all
animalistic and [__] trying hard and
getting into it it's addictive once you
start it and uh if you're if you're
enhanced what you're taking [__]
effort feels good it starts to you know
it's not the same as if you were just
natural especially at our age at our
ages so um yeah and it kind of [__]
unleashes the Beast man but uh she's
changed a [__] ton a lot lot of the
video that we have that we sell on on on
vids many vids many vids I look at it
and I go like man she doesn't even look
like that anymore no I've lost a lost
[__] 30 lbs probably at least yeah I
probably lost 30 lbs since and and the
body configuration has changed lot
change yeah the way she's [__] shape
is totally different it's super weird
yeah and uh how quickly it happens yeah
it happens fast like I can't get over
like I'll wake up I'm like oh my god
look how flat my stomach is yeah that I
that I never used to have that month
yeah cuz I always had the little little
Pooch belly yeah and she's uh got two
more months on this cycle yeah so it's
going to change a lot um Skin's having a
hard time keeping up with it yeah that's
the only that's the only concern but
hopefully it'll in certain areas in
certain areas it looks [__] like
uh papery you know talking about where
you're CU there's not much support there
you're just [__] shrinking down but
will fill you back up with muscle and
and under the influence of this stuff
your your skin will be more elastic
because collagen production is one of
the things that happens you know when
you you know how you get kind of [__]
that weird sweaty kind of clammy feeling
on it [__] there's collagen and
Productions happen mine's not as bad as
yours but I do have that yeah well
you're not you're not on anywhere near
what I'm on you kind of for a while you
smelled like Elmer's Glue which like I
said it's not a bad smell it's just kind
of weird like you can smell Elmer's Glue
probably now you smell like a match head
burnt matches like phosphorus yeah which
actually I like that smell so it doesn't
really bother me it's better than the
glue that's for sure yeah smell like
glue and and the bed would would smell
like glue I'd like smell his side of the
bed and i' be like o it smells like
Elmer's over here yeah you remember
you're a kid you take Elmer's glue and
you put it in your hand you'd roll like
make all that stuff it's what it smells
like and then let it dry and then peel
it off yeah that's what it smells like
yeah I think every kid did that yeah and
I don't know what it is it's
just a lot of things change when you're
on cycle just [__] everything smells
[__] strong yeah bad yeah piss out
nuclear waste looking bright yellow you
know that kind oh [__] you tell me Brown
yeah oh that's nasty and [__] uh I
have not had that yeah and it smells
like [__] burnt coffee you know [__]
like that yeah oh you didn't tell me
that you're not on a lot of it yeah I
know I'm not even really on a lot L of
it yeah I haven't noticed anything like
that no but I have noticed like more I
don't I don't smell weird I just have to
put deodorant on a bunch of times when I
didn't have to before it's all synthetic
testosterone variants basically it's
basically testosterone just trick I kind
of smell like a sweaty teenage boy not
quite no well not as bad as that I don't
think but I never used this girls make
it too yeah um now you're knowwhere near
as bad as a boy no no I don't think I
smell that bad yeah but still like it's
bad for me yeah she got another comment
the other day asking her if she was post
or preop another I was sitting there
going well I thought of well I thought
of a funny answer and then I was like
nah I'm just going to I'm just going to
let it hang there like ignored what and
I'm like I listen to her voice CU they
just want attention and I'm just like I
don't really want to get I listen to her
voice that is rougher than it was yeah
but that's just still a woman's voice
these [__] I let her did did you ever
hear bakar you hear bakar's voice yeah
hers is [__] rougher than yours yeah
and and and she is obviously a [__]
attractive chick right in her 30s you
know muscular and [__] and she's not
[__] she doesn't look like a
bodybuilder she's just like wellness and
that's what she's in she you know and
they still got dudes [__] going like
ah she looks like a man then you look
look at her next to her boyfriend no not
at all [__] I mean they CU her
[__] boyfriend is [__] huge you
know they all did they all send them
from like the little red incel forums
over there to like go go police
everyone's sexuality know and cry about
it no a lot of the a lot of those guys
actually like Fitness girls like the uh
well if you're talking about like those
red pill guys they like those Fitness
girls CU they they're Gym Rats too A lot
of those guys so no they don't they that
that doesn't bother them I think what's
BO I think who's writing that kind of
[__] and and I've track down you know on
Instagram some of these dudes that say
crazy [__] about Fitness girls that I'll
follow they'll say some some [__] now
they get piled on on those Instagram
girls uh [__] accounts cuz that's
their fans you know what I mean and lot
of those guys are gym
rats so some guy will say something like
you know she look like a man and then
like if you see who that is it's one of
two [__] type of guys it's a
[__] a young guy from [__]
Pakistan or India and he's like a
[__] buck 10 that's what he weighs
all right
skinny and and from his point of view
yeah that probably is like a man she
could whip your ass right [__] you
know she's 145 PBS is probably [__]
all muscle you know 150 pounds pure
she'd Whi it she'd whip that skinny
dude's
ass U the other the other main type is
kind of like the dudes off the new male
memes you know if you know what that is
dude with a
[__] goofy ass [__] grin fat
living in his mom's
basement well that's kind of who I
picture yeah that's not that's not the
incel guys um although some incels are
those dudes are incels that's not the
incel scene that's who I talk about no
it's a fat ball of
estrogen uh with scruffy beard and
okay basically remember Chad yeah
imagine like Chad but like a a lot worse
yeah yeah like that well yeah that's who
I picture but Chad
wasn't he wasn't extreme he was just
bad they got them even worse than that
yeah I know I've seen them where they
they lack so much character they lack so
okay all
right who's a little dude not Juan uh uh
oh I know you're talking about yeah that
dude the [__] the the the the well
actually guy I'm not going to say his
name you know who I'm talking about they
got guys like that that are just like
Candyman yeah they got guys that are
like that God that dude's insufferable
yeah just insufferable
they're fat scruffy
[__] bad facial hair bad hair bad
clothes um they hang out in [__] um
like micro Brewery type
bars and basically goofy
Smiles uh goofy
face and um don't take anything
seriously everything is like some kind
of a joke you know you know those guys
because they don't really have any
experience so like a big
child they're kind of like children
yeah it's those guys yeah and
yeah compared to you yeah you would be a
Man compared to that dude I'm all right
with that yeah you'd be
yeah you know [__] little bitty small
testicles you know [__]
y looked like they didn't go through
puberty properly yall just mad because I
got a sexier voice in y and I know more
about horror movies than you so suck it
no I'm just saying but yeah she gets
more chicks than you too uh that is also
the case
so I'm
not because that's really
funny no I was going to well no like I
said cuz that that comment I saw that I
just kind of rolled my eyes and I was
just like man I'm just not going to
answer it but then I thought of like a
really funny answer I said oh I should
probably just put something like cuz
they said um are they what what they say
so are you postop or preop or something
like that yeah yeah I said well I mean
if you're referring to the surgery that
I recently got to remove
my remaining patience for stupid
comments like that and I guess I'm
[__] posttop aren't I yeah but uh but
yeah so I I don't know like I said
people like that just want attention and
I just think it's better I know that
there's like other schools of thought
people are like oh you should clap back
and stuff like that but it's just like I
don't care enough it'll just feed it and
um then they'll just like I said they
want attention and I take great Delight
in not giving it to
[Laughter]
them I don't I just think it's
funny I just think it's fun like I said
I don't really care enough yeah dud call
him tofu men yeah like tofu men tofu men
e tofu they're like if you ever there
there's like a me says new maale n u m a
l e and they're just dudes with big
[__] uh soy face Smiles this big
[__] gigantic goofy [__] smile
remember those things [__] mini me
used to do that [__] smile and take a
picture of himself like that yeah
[__] ridiculous though that I think
that's out of style now but they
probably still got dudes that do that
probably yeah mini me was one of those
it's just that he wasn't overweight he
was skinny yeah he was really skinny he
was just really skinny skinny and
decided to get some Style
that he that he copied from me that he
copied from me and [__] up [__] it
up too he he like bought all of your
same outfits whatever I had he'd buy it
and then he'd [__] buy that same
outfit in a color I would never own like
neon orange and [__] oh that's right I
forgot about and then he would claim
then he would claim to be he was he was
he was a [__] uh he was being
original you being original it was the
same coat it was same Co I got that same
coat dude in Black a different color
yeah you had a black one and a red one
and I think you had a white one you had
a white one too but uh but yeah he
bought a like a had a black one white
one damn brick it was brick yeah yeah
like a like a blood red like a blood red
yeah yeah um I'm going back there's like
a whole bunch of comments I missed uh
Mandy said talking about uh piercings
tongues are always gross probably the
grossest like piercing a tough steak
yeah I can imagine that's another one
that I don't think I would do yeah
probably hurt like crazy it probably
hurts a lot I would imagine um green
spark says you're a badass I waited like
four months I guess in between oh the
two nipples did the same I just wanted
to get it over with like I was I was
like I can't have just one because I'm a
Libra and I like everything balanced I
don't believe in astrology but I'm just
saying I like [__] you know I can't just
have one it's lopsided so I was like I
got to I got to Buck up and get this
other one yeah but uh yeah Tammy said uh
that she she said it sounds gross also
the tongue piercing should I sat with my
daughter as she got hers done yeah yeah
yikes Oracle says uh your face shape
looks more honed Jenny thank you yeah it
does another thing we've been doing too
other than losing weight is we got these
uh what do they call them jaw exerc
they're like Jaw exerciser things
they're like these little kind of like
hard rubber Pebble things yeah kind of
like a juicy fruit yeah a juji fruit you
put it in your mouth you chew and you
chew it like really hard they got soft
medium hard yeah a lot of people don't
really when you're on gear you get real
fat fast muscle response to muscles that
haven't been worked out hard if you work
out that same muscle over and over again
and you don't increase the weight it
doesn't it just it'll just maintain it
won't really get
bigger well one of the one of the
muscles or couple of the muscles that
modern people don't use much is the
[__] jaw muscle because your food is
soft as [__] you guys yeah we're not
basically we eat basically [__] baby
food we're not we're not tearing raw
meat off of like
meat and all that kind of [__] you know
which is what teeth are for that's what
jaw muscles are for so you get these
[__] things and you chew on them if
you're on gear it'll [__] give you
that [__] I I you'll get I got lines
here right do in you got to see it in
certain lights but I got a lines that go
down both sides of my face actually it
doesn't go through the cheeks it's just
here and
here and it's just from chewing cuz a
lot of The Chew muscles are in your head
yeah and if you're you
know if you're B if you're getting
jacked and you're bald your head shape
especially if you're on gear your head
shape's going to change you get look
just more on the
anol you start you start getting these
[__] you get like that big Beetle
Brown yeah you you move your head and
all the [__] your shit's [__] your
[__] [__] head Meats moving all
the time you know Head meat yeah muscles
oh now I kind of want to R write a novel
called Got Your Head meat moving down
there head like head cheese you can have
your head meat and your head cheese so
you got to work all that
out cu if you're on gear you try to work
out everything might as well so we got
those and they and they do like they do
seem to work some you know yeah you kind
of tighten up your jawline yeah yeah
yeah yeah Mandy said that's what I need
to up is my collagen I'm eight months
postpartum and I've lost 40 pounds but
the last 15 is taking forever how old is
she I don't know okay a lot of it has to
do with your age um there's certain
things you can do at certain ages and
other things you can't do at certain
ages when it comes to
[__] how do I say hormone
replacement you can do it at any age but
the younger you are the more the risks
yeah older you are the more you can get
away with
it because the older you are if you're
post
menopausal or if you're like post and
and androgena ause which is like male
menopause is about 50 if you're after
that time you can do whatever the [__]
you want if you know what you're doing
because your body doesn't make very many
hormones so you put a bunch of them in
there when we were talking about uh and
your body's fully formed so it's already
C if you do this to teenagers it can
[__] them up because they're not fully
formed go ahead now what you say uh Zach
says I like the smell of gasoline I have
no idea why when we were talking about
the smells I kind of like the smell of
gasoline too like I don't love it but
I'm just kind of like it's kind of one
of those gross awesome smells green
Sparks says uh talking about the the
incel dudes or they're fat as hell slobs
that all want Barbies well yeah yeah
yeah exact yeah those dudes are tripping
well yeah that's what I mean it's like
they look like that but it's just kind
of like well you have to be like super
hot and perfect so I'm just like no
that's although I got a hand to those
dudes at least those guys aspire to
something the dudes that okay
I was just telling Sophie about this
because we were talking about this
[__] activist out in New York they're
showing videos of I saw the video of
that guy [__] stabbing him to death
in front of his girlfriend and the
pitiful [__] defense he put up for
himself I mean that [__] to die
in front of your
woman after some [__] like that [__]
that that dude must have felt really
bad I mean he couldn't even put up that
that dude was only that kid was only 18
and smaller than him by several inches
that dude was not all that [__] built
and that dude was the white guy was in a
[__] silly ass [__] suit they came
back from some kind of
wedding you see the security
camera something happened that the guy
came back to him he must have said
something I don't know what happened
came back to him and stabbed him and the
guy's just pushing him away he's not
[__] leaning into him and [__]
trying to beat on a dude and take the
knife away and he turns arounder runs
and trips over a
[__] bus
[__] that guy runs over there and just
goes Bam Bam hits him twice in the neck
right in front of his girlfriend kills
him and then she runs up tries to talk
sense to the guy and that guy turned on
her and he was getting ready to plunged
that knife into her and he stopped
himself and spit in her face and then
ran they arrested him later on he was
only 18
crazy well clearly he got pissed but
um anyway
I just see this [__] that these dudes
and these and this happened in New York
you know what I
mean when I lived in Boston I always
kind of had an image that dudes from New
York could handle their business that
they were a little tough I don't know
what happened in New York recently well
maybe they weren't from there I think no
he was he was from Massachusetts that
dude was from
Massachusetts but you know it's 4:00 in
the morning they're just hanging out
outside and [__] looking like a
Target and dude didn't ever prepare for
defense for himself much less his
girlfriend he's lucky that that kid
decided not to stab his girlfriend cuz
he was already dead couldn't defense her
you know and had that guy been a
professional criminal he would have
killed that woman that way she couldn't
ID him so when he got into the courtroom
they could confuse his identity and
there be maybe be some doubt whether or
not that was the same guy you
know but he let her live he's going to
go to prison now had he killed her he
probably would have gotten away with it
cuz the video camera is not the video
footage is not that good from that right
right so a professional criminal kills
all
Witnesses because if you because
especially if you killed one you might
as well kill the other ones you're not
going to get any additional punishment
for it I don't think he was really
thinking things through yeah what's that
I don't think he was really thinking
things through at that point yeah well
he was only
18 but uh I just think it's [__] sad
that these dudes don't think that
anything bad can happen to them so they
don't even bother to [__] even take
[__] junior high
PE so when bad [__] happens they can't
do anything they just they just get run
through it's just
pitiful and that's the way these like he
talking about
these what do you call them this uh the
these fat guys that want the little
skinny Barbies and
[__] yeah they're they're just they're
just like that at least they aspire to
some [__] oh I should get a hot wom
you're never going to get one yeah but
they don't think they have to do
anything yeah [__] get that they
think they can just sit there in their
basement playing video games fall out of
the guy they don't understand the forces
by which women
operate women go out with guys who can
Pro can do something for them they have
to be a move
up okay and it's usually status but
there's other factors too women tend to
choose guys that are good-look better
than them the better if if if he looks
better than her that's going to get him
in the door like that it won't seal the
deal but it'll get him in the
door
so if this dude's a [__] he's a slug
and he's trying to go for Barbie he's
[__] tripping unless he's a
trillionaire a billionaire and then
she's not into you for you it's the
money and the status and if you don't
have a good personality but a [__]
there's all kinds of stories of
[__] paid escorts lived with a dude
for 20 years and he was a billionaire
but he was like so obese he couldn't
walk and
when she was she liked him but when he
died she expected to
get in in The Inheritance and you know
he wasn't there it's just funny you know
what these guys think I I don't
understand
it usually to get a girlfriend stay
first step is you got to be better
looking than her that's the best way and
then that's just getting in you in the
door then you have to go through all the
other
Hoops you know cuz a lot of goodl
looking dudes ain't
[__] you know they open their mouths and
then
they they don't know what to say or
they're running so many women that that
woman decides to reject him because she
doesn't want to fight the whole [__]
team of other women that are competing
for him because if the guy is that goodl
looking and he's that successful he's
got five or 10 of them competing for for
him he's going to get them all he's not
going to marry any of them why would he
get
married maybe when he's 40s or 50s
maybe Danny Rowling said just saw the
1983 sci-fi alien flick strange Invaders
with Nancy Allen and Lise Fletcher oo
which was really good especially the
human alien transformation scenes and
the Soul collecting scenes remember I
don't think I've ever seen that we
should probably look year was that 83 83
83 there's a couple other movies I've
been wanting to do too I want to do um
alone in the dark uh not the newer one
but the one with uh I think Donald
Pleasants is in it I think that was also
83 or 82 um and there was one other one
that I wrote down that I wanted to do
maybe it was house on Sorority row yeah
I think I might want to do that one
too uh then Danny Rowling says Jenny a
Halloween book review of the 1976 book
space Vampires by Colin Wilson would
make for a good book review yeah that's
the book that inspired the film life
force life force yeah so actually I
wouldn't mind reading that because I
love that movie I saw the uh I could
even do like a
comparison I saw some of the conceptual
art for Life Force before it was
actually even they before they even
filmed video of it and the poster was
[__] good man it was I would have
gone and seen that [__] it was a drawing
of a [__] outer space and a spaceship
that was shaped like a [__] coffin or
a cross I don't remember maybe it was a
cross-shaped coffin I know I remember
talking about yeah that's what the alien
spaceships look like sh weird that been
cool that's kind of like the
uh Ric that second Ric movie was kind of
like that yeah yeah where the the
necromongers
yeah greenspark said I argued with some
douchebag the other day who said Marga
Robbie was too old to play Barbie no by
18 to 20 years so she should have been
what 13 ew
czy see I don't know how old margar
Robbie is but she's not that old she
doesn't really look that old to me I
like her she's cute yeah I like her too
yeah I haven't seen Barbie but um but
yeah I I I don't think she's well it's a
doll it's like a
fictional I don't what why do people get
so [__] bent out of shape about
[__] fictional characters man I don't
understand it
um Hollywood actresses aren't what they
used to be you know I remember the when
the
[__] uh when when movies were like
the main medium you know pre-
interet they had some pretty hot ones
but now it just doesn't the Instagram
girl say she's 33 yeah still Prett she's
like a baby yeah still pretty young that
could could that be my kid she could
maybe be my
kid wait I can't M to guys in their 20s
women in their 30s seem old yeah I guess
so they and you know I [__] listen to
some of the some of those red pill guys
you know and the [__] passport Bros
and [__] like that listen to them
talking and it's a mixture you know some
of the guys don't know what they're
talking about other guys know what
they're talking about and kind of have a
more correct response to what's going on
in the dating scene you know but one of
the things that I've noticed that they
tend to get
wrong is
that when a woman gets 30 they say they
call a hit in the wall That's all
downhill after then that that that the
their opportunities have now dried up no
no that that's that's incorrect uh
especially if she's hot and she's 30 no
she's got a lot of life left in her
personally if I was single I would not
[__] with a woman under 30 no way
they're just cuz when you're my age
women in their 20s are doesn't matter
how good-looking they are they're
[__] dumb well like that's young
enough to be her daughter that's well no
it that doesn't mean a [__] thing all
right uh throughout the beginning of
[__] time you had dudes that had
whole Herms of [__] women ranging
from women in their 40s all the way down
into their [__] teens who could have
been young enough to be their
granddaughters and they're still
knocking them up yes Tom I know this men
just do that you know they don't care
it's just about power if you can have
5,000 wives like jenus Khan you do
it um so there there is no moral things
about age really now when you start
talking about [__] young enough to
get you in trouble no it's not [__]
worth it you know what I mean and then
they don't have anything to offer other
than the children they can give that uh
I don't even think the sex would be that
good because they don't have very much
experience but some dudes are into that
because they don't have experience
themselves so it's kind of like they're
on the [__] same level they don't
feel intimidated by them I guess well
yeah I think that's a large part of why
dudes want to go out with like younger
women because they have um status over
them they have power over them and
they're maybe on the same level like you
said maturity level too it's a mixture
Yeah well yeah I didn't say
yeah and it also you have to understand
what you're talking about like some some
people like I talked about Jason STM the
other day Jason St I think is about my
age I think his wife is 21 22 23 around
that age and man them [__] older
women [__] just hating on him you
know the thing is though is you look at
her man and she's cute he doesn't need
anything from a woman in terms of like
he doesn't need a woman that works he's
got money he doesn't need a woman that
has a profession because that just means
that she would be gone all the
time so she's just a companion a friend
you know what I mean and she's probably
you know nice to him and she's fun and
she's pretty that's really when a guy is
all set that's all he needs he just she
just needs to be nice and pretty and
have fun and to get along and that's not
wrong no you know and she's young enough
to where she could have his
kid he can die guy and she gets all his
[__] and she'd be young enough to even
remarry
still you know what I mean MH so that
works out works out for the moment and
she's under the protection of a guy
who's uh got a lot of money and status
you know other women gunning for him and
he chose her so she feels lucky about it
and then they want to attack that girl
even though they would have done it
those women attacking that oh that you
know she doesn't know what she's doing
yeah she doesn't know what she's doing
that's what you're saying yeah she knows
exactly what she's doing if you were in
that same shoes at any age you would
know what you were doing and you'd do it
too so you know women just like to hate
hating on younger
women now there are some guys that
you're talking
about just straight up pedos you know
well yeah that's who I was talking about
yeah just you know he's 50 and he likes
8-year-olds six-year-olds and [__]
there's some mental [__] problems
there you know well obviously and you
know that's uh he's comfortable with
that well if he's I don't know
why you know and some of those dudes
that are like that are also married so I
don't know what what the [__] deal is
I'm sure it's been
studied psychologist have studied but
it's probably some kind of inadequacy
issue oh I'm sure that's part of it yeah
the feeling of
that
that that they were in total control
probably is part of it well I think
that's a major factor because those kind
of
dudes that are into like real young
girls like
that they get off on having total
control over a person yeah you know what
I mean they're young enough to be
malleable yeah you know well I've read
some criminal psychology stuff that and
and read some books about it and that
kind of stuff is mentioned and they say
say that most of those guys don't harm
the kids they actually do love them but
there's there's [__] issues well yeah
you know what I mean uh some of them are
like you know power tripping though yeah
um other ones they just think it's where
it's like it's like the the dude is
mentally regressed he regresses back to
a
child when he's with that child that's
another thing that they said that they
do in other words you know what I mean
like he's with he he's pretending like
he's eight right you know so I
either way that's let build a pillow
fort yeah yeah exactly although you can
do that as an adult right and then and
but they like sex is involved right
that's but you know that's where the
issue AR yeah so it's weird you know
that that's some kind of sexual
orientation built on some kind of mental
problem now what's the weird thing
though is that was that going on with
Michael
Jackson we've never done a show about
Michael Jackson I think ACC to one I'm
not sure where I stand on that that um
oh man I'd say by all accounts all the
evidence is there to say that [__]
Michael Jackson was in [__] AA he was
he was in I mean I I lean toward that
end also yeah there's some suspicious
[__] I mean I wasn't there but here's
the thing there's a couple things that
are in his
favor the people that accused him
evidently had a [__] history of
accusing people and uh that that that
seems that that really did look like a
setup that one kid what his name Cory
Hayes the guy that was got with the the
that actor well no Cory Felman was it
for Cory Felman is that the one he' been
molested by some directors and [__] like
that when he was a kid yeah I thought
well Cory is dead yeah think I think
think the dude is dead oh okay it's one
of the two one of those Corey guys one
of the Cory said he was friends with
Michael Jackson and he said no Michael
Jackson wasn't like
that yeah see that's what I mean I'm not
real sure because it's like there's yeah
like the way he behaves seems creepy but
then like he the way he grew up was real
weird was weird and it's like just the
fame that he got like from a kid was
weird and it's just like so you can kind
of understand where he was coming from
so maybe you know maybe all the weird
[__] he was doing was kind of innocent
but it just looked [__] up to us cuz
that's how it usually I think it was you
guys can you guys go correct me somebody
there knows was it Cory Hayes or Cory
Feldman that knew it there was friends
with him I thought it was Cory Feldman
wasy Felman is still alive though Cory
Felman vouched for him said he went over
there all the time and hung out with and
he was a little boy during that time and
and hung out there with other little
boys and [__] he said that Michael
Jackson was not like that that he was he
thought from what I recall Corey thought
that Jackson liked to regress himself to
a boy likee state state of mind yeah so
he could live out
childhood yeah he seemed very much to
have like a Peter Pan thing like a Peter
Pan thing he wanted to become a child
again
right and the evidence kind of shows
that he wanted to be a white
child that's that's what he got all the
little statues are all these little
white Peter Pan boys and he did look I
mean the the surgeries that he did to
himself man come on he was transracial
he was trying he was becoming white he
was put on white makeup he you know
whiter than a Caucasian you
know and he evidently mod his face after
uh we had to do a show on him man that's
what I'm saying yeah maybe I should put
that in the poll next we cuz I was
growing up D with during this [__] and
when it was going on it was a I think it
would be good because it's like I don't
really I don't have a dog in that fight
and it's like I don't really
know what went on you know what I mean
like yeah he seemed like a pedo but
maybe not yeah maybe we're projecting
[__] onto him I don't know know it might
be our problem but what I well I mean to
be fair to us the do wrong way 99.9% of
dudes that do that are are that yeah if
I was a prosecutor I'd be trying to
charge that dude sure all right because
because like it's all there yeah nine
times out of 10 that's what's going on
right there's a good video on it by a
guy who um his name his name is Razer
fist on YouTube he did a great show on
he's a heavy metal guy he um does uh
music reviews political commentary and
everything most of heavy metal but he
was a Michael Jackson fan
and um he did a whole show on on the
Michael Jackson
case and he went to bathroom says no it
wasn't and he he shoots holes in the in
in the basic media's story of it the
people that accused him had accused
other people the the before and it was
was money related he
thought that it was a setup that they
set Michael Jackson up a fan family
trying to make money off of it which is
entirely possible yeah especially you
know with the reputation that he had for
yeah the weird [__] that he would do and
according to razor Fist and this may be
true I left California when I was a kid
in 81 he said in the California area
around Hollywood is an entire subculture
of parents trying to basically pimp
their kids out to people in Hollywood so
they can sue them is that's like a
thing
so doesn't I don't doubt it I mean [__]
weirder [__] has happened
like Catholic school girls being pimped
out to local cops and politicians and
the nun finds out and gonna go rat and
they [__] killed her well that was
the Kathy snic case Kathy snic case you
know so they did a whole Min series of
that sounds like something out of a
[__] movie I wrote about that case
but that happened because they haven't
solved it yeah that happened that part
of the Catholic church that Catholic
School it was a Catholic School wasn't
it yes Catholic School for Girls they
were pimping out there some of those
girls to the cops MH and and local
politicians MH and it was like a school
that I mean
allegedly oh no no no there were girls
who said that that did happen to him
well yeah yeah yeah I know but I'm just
saying that it's like you
know Green spark not all of them just
some of them there girls that would get
in trouble put them in detention and
[__] they'd [__] [__] their minds up
they'd take them out [__] hand them
over to the cops a certain cop and cop
would rape him and then they'd take him
to politicians would
pay local politicians and it was like
wasn't Governors but [__] like Mayors
and stuff wasn't it yeah something like
that it's been a long time since I've
seen that yeah right yeah I
mean tack [__] and the nuns were
involved dudes are the worst nuns being
all lesbo and [__] I'd be a lesbian too
if you were none cuz dudes are the worst
mhm well look at was like you know the
fact that they had enough customers hey
we got all these Catholic school girls
that are all kind of like having all
these mental issues let's pimp them out
and like all of these cops and people
who should know better oh absolutely I'm
going to line up for that here take my
money well it was unclear like you are
also it was unclear how many cops yeah I
don't know how many cops it was I don't
remember like I said the whole Force no
no
no but it was more than one
yeah greenpark says about Michael
Jackson I think he kind of also wanted
to become Diana Ross yeah what I was no
not Diana Ross who was the one he had
his face modeled after
um his friend his white girl actress um
oh what's her face um what was her name
yeah yeah
yeah black hair Elizabeth Taylor
Elizabeth Taylor yeah that's right yeah
he wanted to look like Elizabeth Taylor
he was friends with Elizabeth Taylor
when she was old well they they didn't
get that right but okay
evidently he was trying to get his nose
to be like Elizabeth Taylor he wanted to
look like Elizabeth Taylor's transgender
son or something I guess I don't
know and um the doctor told him that
that wasn't
possible that the nose he was wanted
wasn't possible he told him to do it
anyway that [__] came out botched so
then he covered his face for a long time
he didn't want anybody to see what his
new nose looked like CU he already had
it worked on two or three
times uh I don't know what his nose look
like I'll keep my nose thanks he had
that
DB he he wor a surgical mask all the
time it kind of looked like a skull nose
for a while they just kept shaving
shaving more and more off bit off of it
yeah and he actually looked good had he
stopped right around the Thriller time
he looked good right there I I would
have just stopped then he he kept going
he just kept on going yeah well it was
just kind of like when he when he was on
the cover of the Bad album he looked a
little weird that nose didn't fit him
still was human nose yeah still like
human looking yeah he looked like but as
it went on he start then it got worse
yeah yeah Danny roll said Skeletor no
yeah he started looking like a skull
face which you know yeah not great and
he like you can't just keep like shaving
Parts on it's like they can't put it
back you know what I mean maybe they can
nowadays but the rumor that I had heard
is that that the doctor told him that
look that what you're asking for you
can't be done that's it that that nose
is it's finished you can't you can't cut
any more off that he told him do you
keep throwing a bunch of money at a
doctor eventually he's like yeah you
sign this waiver you know that kind of
[__] well yeah I mean if I was a doctor
and I'm and I had told them like look I
in good conscience I don't feel like I
can do this I've told you it's going to
look [__] up I'm telling you this
right now and he just says we'll do it
anyway I'm going to give you $5 million
I'd be like okay but I've already told
you so you can't [__] sue me you got
to sign all this other [__] yeah now he
bought children too that's another
creepy thing yeah he said that that was
with some kind of surrogate mother that
he had or he had two of them one one of
his name was blanket I blanket what was
the other one I don't remember blanket
named the kid blanket that's some [__]
up [__] he's crazy all right but when
you look at those kids man it it's cute
when when they're a baby yeah that's a
cute baby name yeah or like a baby
nickname yeah but like when you're an
adult hi I'm blanket yeah then what now
yeah I saw photographs of the of of the
surrogate mom and she white girl you
know yeah look like from [__]
Switzerland or some [__] those babies
came out they look like they were from
[__] Sweden all right and I'm going
like uhuh hell no hell no there's not an
ounce of Michael Jackson in those babies
not an ounce well yeah he probably just
not possible yeah he he bought them
there's no way he probably just said I'm
not you know he either hired a girl that
was already pregnant or said to somebody
hey if you're going to get pregnant and
you don't want the kid like you want to
put him out for adoption adoption I'm
willing to pay x amount of money yeah to
purchase the child which happens a lot
yeah you know it's kind of [__] up but
it happens a
lot remember when remember when him and
Lisa Marie Presley got married for a
minute yeah and remember how everybody
wasw weirded out about it and then like
what awards show was that it was like
MTV video music award I don't remember
what award show it was they were making
fun of us like but then like they're
like oh we really did get married it's
not like and then they kissed on the
show and everybody's like oh now we're
really sure that it's not cuz it was
just like so awkward yeah like
uncomfortable yeah and I'm like now
everybody's really thinks that it's like
not real it looked fake as [__] it
didn't it was I think I think according
to the interviews that I I remember
seeing I think Lisa Marie thought that
he was really interested in her and I
also think that he had promised to help
her recording yeah probably I'd imagine
but that didn't happen no okay and then
as soon as the [__] PR thing was over
he just kind of vanished he just need he
used her I think he just used her it did
kind of seem like that yeah he used her
to deflect away from the [__] pedo
yeah it's like look I'm totally
hetosexual
Yeah man they looked like two
uncomfortable lesbians up there actually
to see those two together looked like
uncomfortable lesbians or it looked like
to me it almost looked like a brother
and sister yeah kissing yeah that's kind
of what it reminded me of and I was like
it like two family members it was so
gross
yeah and not that either one of them is
physically gross it's just the vibe yeah
between them was really gross it was
really UNC comfortable but uh yeah and I
still remember that too I don't remember
what that was a long time ago was that
back in the [__] '90s or some [__]
yeah maybe maybe the 90s that was back
when Lisa Marie still was still cute she
still looked young too she yeah I think
she did didn't she like put one album
out or something she put out several
albums they all bombed
yeah it just that doesn't work I kind of
felt bad for her though yeah it it never
it never works to where you know your
dad was a famous singer so you're going
to automatically have fans it doesn't
work that way you got to come up through
a club scene and tour and be a nobody
and well you got to kind of make your
own way I feel like yeah I mean that
didn't even that [__] didn't even work
for [__] uh the the the sons of the
dudes that were in The Beatles you know
see and that's the thing I kind of feel
like that's really a double-edged sword
because you're always well on the one
hand you have you you know you have an
automatic in because your mom or your
dad or whoever was like super famous so
it's like you have all these connections
that you can use that a normal person
wouldn't have so you might be able to
like bypass some stuff that just some
regular you know plea would have to go
through but then on the other hand
everybody's going to know who your
famous parent is and one they're going
to compare you oh it's not as good and
also people are going to accuse you of
just using or like riding on their
coattails some said somebody said Joe
Jackson was packing a Mac you talking
about Joe Jackson the guy did what was
it stepping out I love that song was
that Joe Jackson yeah I think that was
Joe Jackson that might be the guy I
actually I actually love that song he's
running around with a Mac I mean he he
did more songs than that but I that's
the one I remember the best I had a Mac
10 too I had an Ingram Mac
10 they took it from me though the MPS
took it from me and some [__]
[__] spread eagle I had it on the
motorcycle in a tank bag coming through
the main gate for Campbell well and they
said they took it from me they says you
can't have it that's operating that's
operating [__] uh vehic that's
operating a vehicle [__] within Arms
Reach of a weapon I said it's inside
here I can't get taken out of this bag
you know they took it from me but then
the cops are like no okay we're not
going to charge you just have uh tell
your Battalion Commander we need to
letter from your Battalion Commander
[__] so you can get it back and I
said oh [__] no because [__] they
would have given me an article the
commander would have given me an Article
15 cuz he he was just an [__] so I
let him keep
it I didn't pay much for it in those
days
I think maybe
350 but I should have man I wish I still
had it it was a semi-auto [__] Ingram
Mac 10 one of the old ones it look like
a damn box it wasn't a
cobra and uh it was 9mm though it wasn't
the it wasn't the
45 wish I still had it though it' be
worth a lot of money Danny ring said no
Joe Jackson the father of Michael
Jackson oh okay okay and then he said as
if he penetrated that broad let alone
any female some say his dad had
Michael's ball bag snipped off to keep
his voice sounding youthful but who
knows I don't believe it I have heard
that rumor too but I don't I don't
believe it I mean weirder things have
happened but you'd need some
extraordinary evidence to come up with
there'd be easier ways to do that sure
they had they had testosterone blockers
that could do
that yeah that was just a hormone
blocker yeah but it has bad side effects
if you take them
young they have it's bad side effects
period you you you don't want to be a
man and have real low
testosterone when it starts going down
just as low as a girl or
something you'll have all kinds of
[__] problems like osteoporosis and
[__] yeah Ben says castrate yeah you
also get real fat lower your
testosterone the fatter you're going to
get then the fatter you get the the
lower the testosterone you produ so it's
like an endless Circle that's why I was
making fun of these dudes up the bar
there just a little ball of [__]
estrogen
little fat boy not a [__] ounce of
testosterone and scraggly little beards
and [__] [__] pushing 40 but he
looks like he sounds like a little kid
and he kind of looks like a
20-year-old like it's like like puberty
didn't happen right it's weird man I
don't know what they're not from here
they're not the ones that I'm talking
about the other day me and white girl
Whisperer saw them at the bar we you
know you know where you know where
uh Throwbacks across the street from
Throwbacks there's a bar over there okay
you seen
that probably I've walked around down
there a lot it's a micro Brewery it
looks like a place where some [__] oh
I know what you're talking about I know
you're talking about looks like some I
don't know some hippie crunchy granola
people yeah I can't remember the name of
it but I know what you're talking about
in there it's
like it attracts a lot of people that
would be I would call them kind of like
Northern types I w't call them Yankees
that might [__] make people
uncomfortable but they move here you
sound like my granddad Yankees yeah it's
you should have heard my [__] Grand
my grandmother talk about Yankees yeah
my grandfather my dad my dad hated him
too
but this is Mississippi [__] here man I
I I'll go [__] deep Delta [__]
Mississippi on your asses I bring back
the [__] the whole war and everything
but uh we went in there white girl
whisper
[__] Jenny's going to meet him he's
going to he's stopping by we'll see if
he comes out tonight we'll see don't let
him whisper too much let him you can let
him whisper a little bit but don't
[__] let him whisper too much I'm not
going anywhere I don't fall for that
he's going to try to [__] make a
trade or something no I'm just that's
what you said you said like no that [__]
doesn't work on me no I'm just [__]
around none of that [__] works on
me the name Lloyd Lloyd's actually cuz I
don't care what people say and I don't
listen to them anyways Lloyd's Jamaican
American his parents are from
Jamaica and they they they they own a
Jamaican restaurant over there near the
mall up the street from it's not it's
not the one you thought it was it's oh
okay so it's a different there's a
there's two down there oh okay that was
just the one I thought of that's one I
pass all the time that's that one but
there's another one not even a mile away
there's another one all
right this dude's [__] He's
physically gifted I mean he's
uh about I think he's
36 he's
about 5'9 probably about 200 lb
maybe 10 15% body fat no probably about
10 to 12% body
fat and [__] you look at him man he
looks like he looks like he's on gear he
looks like he's working out that dude
has not touched a weight in his life
just [__] I was just man [__] I
can't believe yeah it's all just genetic
anyway we walk in there and [__]
we're looking at these dudes and we're
just
like they don't come from here they they
move here from up
North I guess the economy driv driving
them out of there or they move here for
something the weather usually weather
eventually drives them out though I
think the I think the I think they can't
stand the heat well I can't blame them
cuz I was born here and I also can't
stand the heat that's awful yeah they
never really kind
of they never become Southern I guess
you could say they always seem like
they're tourists they never really adapt
now their kids probably do if they have
kids but I haven't
really I don't know any kids from people
up north that have here do you well
everybody well yeah everybody I know is
from somewhere else somewhere else right
I'm one of the very few people that was
born in this state I'm not from here
either I'm but you
know it's it's honestly it's pretty rare
when I was in high school I knew one
girl that was born here she was born in
Gainesville like Tom Petty I'm from a
southern family though based out of my
dad was from Mississippi my mother was
from
Virginia so
um but a lot of the people that move
here are also Southern too but
Mississippi is actually a lot like the
Florida Panhandle there's no difference
between the Panhandle Mississippi and
Alabama Alabama yeah that's it's it's
the same well we just I mean the
Panhandle we just call it Alabama South
yeah yeah there are three floridas the
Panhandle Central which is the Orlando
area this is like are yeah this is like
party central really and then there's
the the Miami area South Florida and
that's North it's north Cuba basically
other than like Key West which is kind
of like New Orleans but not quite right
you know it's got all that pirate stuff
going on on it yeah it's like pirate
well I guess New Orleans has pirate [__]
too yeah that's yeah New Orleans is a
pirate yeah that's what Cove but I mean
well well honestly that whole that's why
Tampa and all that kind of stuff will p
Tampa has gasp Barilla that's like the
pirate festival yeah they have big
parades and all this kind of [__] so
it's like Marty gr but
pirate yeah they have that every year I
don't remember when it is
though I don't I don't think I ever
went yeah Jeffy art said South Florida
where I live Tom speaks the truth yeah
yeah I haven't been down there much I've
been to Fort Lauderdale a couple times
I've been to Miami a couple times still
have never been to the Everglades
although I would love to go and I've
never been to Key West I kind of feel
like I should because I probably would
really dig it but even in this area here
we have New Yorkers like when I go down
to the [__]
Oasis you know the biker bar they got
guys from new well a lot of people
retire here like I said CU it's it's hot
yeah they're old though they gu people
from New York they even had some guys
from Canada come here they're they're
old they're retired tell you man those
[__] those bikers come in there like
those warlocks they come in there you
treat them like [__] man it's [__]
funny some of the funny [__] I've
seen
they had about six of them walk in there
and one of them pointed at one of the
Yankees he says y'all better stay off
that [__] juke box while we're in
here I don't want to hear any that
goddamn what what was he
didn't told him not to play it better
not be playing at [__] Neil
Young that Bruce Springsteen up in here
all right we listen to the Eagles that
kind of
[__]
it's all the same to me to be honest
it's like it's hilarious to me that
these old farts are still like those
arguing about that crap no the warlocks
weren't old the warlocks wer they were
40s but they were saying that to the
[__] well no I don't mean old in age
I mean old in Attitude yeah is what I me
they bullying yeah they're younger than
me but it's just like don't tell me what
to do with my [__] jukebox I was here
before you [__] you want to hear oh you
don't want to tell them that they're
[__] I'll play with whatever the [__]
I want my you out you know just saying
High Desert says uh I've never been to
Florida you're not really missing much
to be honest with you uh Mandy said
lived in pompo Beach yeah I've been
there as well Hollywood Fort Lauderdale
now I'm in West Palm so she's in Florida
too yeah yeah I haven't been in South
Florida a lot like I said I've been
everywhere in Central Florida cuz like I
said I grew up in Daytona lived in Tampa
Clearwater area for a little while and
then last 15 years been in the central
Florida been in Orlando OVO Winter Park
that kind of area and now we're in
Eustace which is Eustace is like it's
kind of rural it's like all farms and
stuff but it's only it's about 18 miles
from downtown Sanford and about 28 miles
from downtown Orlando yeah is about so
it's like an easy drive so you can go
out if you want to but it's still like
kind of out here with all farms and [__]
yeah Central Florida is nice I like
Central Florida it it's it's good I I've
lived all over the South I've lived in
[__] Massachusetts I lived in
California lived in Brazil Egypt lived
all over and I like Central
Florida you know it's one of the best
places in the South um well it kind of
has something for everybody for
everybody yeah like it is like Central
Florida um you know it's got rednecky
[__] I mean I I grew up in Daytona and
that's a lot more rednecky and kind of
trashy like white trash but um there's a
lot of that in Orlando too but then
there's like millions of other yeah
there you know there's kind of like I
said something forget about the British
influence though too there there there's
also a lot of British people that live
here yeah this this Central
Florida was a British colony I believe
for a while was there's British colonial
houses that are hundreds of years old
here cuz um I guess they were just
colonizing stuffff making towns it
wasn't downtown what you call it wasn't
that British oh I don't know yeah um
what's what's I don't know what I don't
know what you're talking
about we went to that [__] British
restaurant down there what's the name of
that place Mount Dora Mount Dora I think
Mount Dora was originally British oh
maybe I'd have to look that up yeah I'd
have to look that up there a British
restaurant there owned by British
people yeah we have we got video with
that lady yeah England and Spain and
France well like I said a British
tourist com like British tourists love
[__] Florida man yeah they come and
go to all the theme parks they're here
for like two weeks and they have a
[__] great time the original
Floridians though are the Cubans it's
like Cubans and the people in the pan
handle and uh s old Indians who were a
mixed mixture of a bunch of different
people they ended up lot a lot of men
are just becoming Americans the other
ones got forced out to the reservation
Indian Territory way back in the day and
they didn't want to go because they
didn't want to live next to the crow
Crow Indians and the seminol hated each
other yeah they didn't get and they were
just like no yes where you you got to go
and it they eventually went down there
but they The Crow and the seminol hated
each other hey Mandy knows that British
restaurant Meat Market or something yeah
it's called the magical meat Boutique
magical meat Boutique magical meat
Boutique that's what it's called they
got great fish and chips it's good yeah
yeah met the owner yeah yeah they're
British chick [__] screaming at
me she was
nice tattoos on her and stuff yeah Mount
Dora is cool it's like it's not big but
it's just like Mount Dora I kind of feel
like that's known for I feel like it's
known for antique shops like a lot of
people go here and go to like antiquing
over there but there's
all oh my God don't talk about me don't
talk about me I didn't even know she was
back there the whole time she's been
back there sleeping in the chair the
whole time I didn't even see her go over
that Jess what time it is I know got to
shut it down I know well hold on Zach
says what are some cool things to see in
Florida that most people don't know of
honestly I kind of feel like
I don't know I kind of like a lot of the
um I don't know if it was more nature
kind of stuff I like all the kind of uh
like
Springs there's a lot of kind of Springs
in Central Florida and a lot of people
don't go to those like Alexander Springs
and Blue Springs and uh I guess Silver
Springs most people know about that but
there's like other ones like in Central
Florida in the ca national forest and
stuff that are actually really cool and
you can camp there and there's
alligators and it's pretty cool like
Blue Springs is kind of
more crowded like more people know about
it and the spring itself is actually
like where you swim and stuff they've
actually kind of um you know sort of
cemented it in to try to keep the
alligators from coming in there and
eating people um and but Blue Springs
does have an
excellent pancake restaurant like you go
in there and there's lines out the
[__] door like all the time you go in
there and they make pancakes like on the
griddle like in front of you and it's
like oh they're really really good um so
I like all of that kind of stuff I like
alligator Farms there's one in St
Augustine that's really cool uh St
Augustine itself is a really cool place
I guess a lot of tourists go there but
if you just come to Orlando like a lot
of people just go to the theme parks and
because there's so much fun stuff to do
in Orlando you know there's restaurants
and nightclubs and theme parks and all
kind of stuff like strip clubs yeah like
all that kind of stuff so you could
spend easily spend two weeks two week
vacation in Orlando and never run out of
[__] to do cuz there's tons of [__] to
do yeah cuz it's very tourist oriented
but I I don't know I kind of like
smaller stuff like I said like like St
Augustine because it's like historical
and I've heard some people griping who'
come here evidently they've come here
for tourist and they go oh man that
whole area is just one big tourist trap
it's all tourist
no saying you everywhere you go you
drive around and it's it it you know you
can see that Disney did this and that
like no no Central Florida looks like a
theme park like the freeways do
everything on the side of the roads it
that's the way the whole thing looks
like that you know but some people think
that that Disney had something to do
with that it
doesn't but it's not a tourist trap well
most people most people that live here
don't hardly ever see any of that stuff
that's
expensive to go you know to go to
[__] what is it going to cost a
couple hundred couple hundred dollars a
person per day to go to Disney
I only been like two or three times I
mean it's cheaper for Florida residents
because they usually give you a deal but
um but yeah we don't really care about
it that much more like conv I I mean I
like it I go to conventions and [__]
but there yeah like we have um Spooky
Spooky Empire comes here every year like
it's a big horror convention adult adult
film conventions [__] we getting
invited to those yeah yeah Ricon yeah
yeah we mighton that's exotic time might
yeah Bill invited us I don't know man uh
Joseph says did you ever visit NASA I
did when I was a kid I went to Cape
Canaveral we used to go every time there
was a shuttle launch like back in the
80s we used to go and I've been like all
through the building and did the tour
and all of that we got to go all right
um yeah we got to go because white girl
whisper me there 9:30 oh he's oh [__]
okay so I think all all you have to do
is tighten my coret and I it'll be fine
all right so we're going to wrap it up
cuz we got to go out and I got to meet
the white girl Whisperer so we're g to
see how this goes hopefully it'll be a
fun night tonight I've only had one
drink so far so I'm going to try
and yeah I'm going to trying to like
keep it down because we spent a lot last
week so you know what I mean but yeah so
we will be back on Monday I'm pretty
sure I already know what movie we're
going to talk about but I'm not going to
spoil it but it's a classic like from
the 70s right yeah so we're going be
talking about that so hopefully you guys
can join us for that thanks for hanging
out with us this Friday evening and
we'll see you guys again on Monday night
good night